Grace Kelly sonder de Mendoza has lived
in germany since 1996 she left her
native by E Y northeastern Brazil to see
a bit of the world and eventually ended
up in Berlin been invited me a fry hi
rami Berlin means freedom for all the
people who live here there's so much
going on so much green space and so many
people from different cultures like when
this Bridge here where we're meeting
it's so beautiful it connects a city
that was once divided I stock before
hair I get 30 crisp and also has a
degree in agriculture at first she did
part-time jobs later she began
organizing parties and soon started
getting requests to play the music that
was her start as a DJ
her first big gig was in two thousand at
the Berlin multicultural festival hi
Matt Glenna so I thousand in the year
2000 of Brazil was the featured country
and it was the first time that i dj'ed
efficiently for a lot of people around a
thousand people it was exciting and
really really wonderful time
after that she began djing at more and
more clubs her concept of mixing
Brazilian music and electronic beats
when a large following since then DJ
Grace Kelly has made herself an
international name in the club scene she
gets bookings all around the world and
she even had her own Berlin radio
program for five years today she lives
in courts back a multicultural district
in the heart of the city when she gets a
craving for the taste of home she heads
to cafe Morty there are plenty of
specialties to choose from one is
feijoada the Brazilian national dish its
a mix of black beans meat and lots and
lots of herbs when it comes to Brazil
hosting the world cup she's skeptical
it's a foog a living there suddenly they
found money for stadiums that will be
used just once and never again but
Brazil needs hospitals it needs schools
it needs a lot of other things and not
the world cup unfortunately but I hope
people will keep protesting and that
this world cup goes down in history if
people will take this as an example
maybe it will need to change I hope so
grace lives for music apart from djing
she also plays in the brazilian band
honey hasta Norte or Queens of the north
they dedicated the song to the world cup
in brazil grace first learned to drum
after she got to Berlin
sounded yeah I took drumming lessons
here with people like doodoo tucci and
others I only learned it here but I used
to play music back in Brazil to whenever
they were playing samba I'd get involved
haha bc my man gimme the highest own or
t have been performing at festivals
across germany since 2003 including the
carnival of cultures in Berlin and on
July thirteenth will be warming up fans
at a public viewing area in Berlin for
the World Cup this event so well myself
a Freddie's I'll be here in Berlin for
the world cup and I'll watch some of the
games I don't know how I'll feel though
I think if people ask me if I want
brazil to win I've got no idea what's
right and Shane and even after the
soccer celebrations are well and truly
over grace Mendoza will still be here
bringing some of that Brazilian feeling
to her new home in brilliant
you